i
plus contagieux.
Normand Grondin.
(sirènes, klaxons)
- Le fameux variant de la COVID
qui a complètement débordé
le système de santé indien
et qui se répand maintenant
dans le monde répond bien
aux vaccins, indique
une nouvelle étude dont les
résultats sont préliminaires.
Selon l'étude, après
deux doses, le vaccin Pfizer est
très efficace contre ce variant.
L'AstraZeneca fait également
du bon travail. Par contre,
la protection est faible
après une seule dose.
On sait également que
ce variant est plus contagieux
que les autres et qu'il devrait
continuer à gagner du terrain
en Europe et ailleurs.
Dr ANDRÉ VEILLETTE, Groupe de
travail sur les vaccins COVID-19
- Présentement, je pense que
le variant britannique est
prédominant. Il a remplacé
le variant de Wuhan ou
la souche originale de Wuhan.
Et je pense que ces variants-là
vont tous avoir des cycles,
puis ils vont se faire remplacer
un après l'autre.
- Le Royaume-Uni a récemment
réduit de quatre semaines
le délai entre l'administration
des deux doses de vaccin pour
les personnes de 50 ans et plus,
une mesure qui pourrait
permettre un meilleur contrôle
du variant indien.
Des données récentes indiquent
également que la protection
offerte par une seule dose de
Pfizer ou d'AstraZeneca est
un peu moins efficace que prévu
pour réduire les symptômes,
les hospitalisations
et les décès, et ce,
peu importe la souche de COVID.
Au Québec, les cas de variant
indien sont encore rares.
Mais réduire les délais
entre deux doses pourrait
quand même être avantageux,
selon ce spécialiste.
- Ça me surprendrait pas que
le 16 semaines qu'on avait
auparavant va devenir
un 12 semaines. Puis je pense
qu'on va peut-être avoir
des annonces à ce sujet-là
bientôt, ce qui serait très
bien. Mais peut-être aussi
qu'il faut réfléchir à savoir
si on devrait même pas
aller plus vite.
- Le variant indien est
maintenant présent dans
une cinquantaine de pays.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, M